let F be a function such that F of
negative 1 is 3 and F prime of negative
1 is equal to 5 let G be the function G
of X is equal to 1 over X let capital F
function to find it as the product of
those other two functions what is
capital F prime of negative 1 well we
can just apply the product rule here let
me just rewrite let me just essentially
state the product rule capital F prime
of X is going to be equal to since
capital f of X is the product of these
two functions we apply the product rule
this is going to be F prime of X times G
of X plus plus f of X times G prime of X
and so if we want to evaluate this at F
at negative 1 capital F prime at
negative 1 is equal to F prime of
negative 1 times G of negative 1 plus
function f evaluated at negative 1 times
the derivative of G evaluated at
negative 1 now let's see if we can
figure these things out so do they tell
us this anywhere can we figure this out
F prime of negative 1 well they tell us
right if your F prime of negative 1 is
equal to 5 so this is equal to 5 now
let's actually stick with F what is F of
negative 1 well they tell that to us
right over here F of negative 1 is equal
to 3 so F of negative 1 is equal to 3
now G G of negative 1 and G prime of
negative 1 they don't give it to us
explicitly here but we could figure it
out we can we know that
well if G of X is equal to this G of
negative 1 is equal to 1 over negative 1
which is equal to negative 1 so this is
equal to negative 1 and then last but
not least if we want to find G prime of
negative 1 we just have to take the
derivative of this so G prime of X
actually let me just rewrite G of X G of
X 1 over X is just the same thing as X
to the negative 1 so we're going to use
the power rule to figure out G prime of
X
is equal to bring that exponent out
front negative one times X to the and
then decrement the exponent negative two
power so G prime of negative 1 of
negative one is equal to negative one
times negative one to the negative two
power and that's just the same thing as
negative one over negative one squared
this is one so this is just all going to
evaluate to negative one so this is
negative one and so we have five times
negative one which is negative 5 plus
three times negative one which is
negative three which is equal to
negative eight so f prime of negative
one is equal to negative eight